Hello, this is Frankie Freitas and we're here at the Center for Holographic Arts in Long Island City, better known as Queens.
And I'm speaking with Shu Min Lin.
How are you?
Hi, good.
Hi everybody.
How are you?
Okay.
Um you've been involved with holography for how long?
Uh has been about ten years.
Ten years now.
And what do you work in?
Uh is most of the work that you do in reflection holography or white light transmission holography?
Um, I do most of uh reflection hologram, but I kind of working on more in much larger scale by having a hologram into the installation.
So um for example, one of my work, I installed the hologram on the floor and that floor takes about one thousand square feet space.
And the uh the entire holographic installation is that size?
Um that would be about like uh for that piece, that particular one I have a one about one hundred holograms mixed with the tiles.
So people the audience can be walk on the the tiles and also the holograms to look at the hologram.
Now is this an exhibit that moves from place to place part of your work or is this uh an exhibit that's in a building that's there permanently?
Uh this piece uh has been traveled to many different countries and currently uh showing in Finland and most of the time it was in the museum space and kind of keep traveling now.
Yeah.
What's your background?
Is your background uh more as an artist or in science and technology?
Uh fine arts, my background.
Fine arts.
What drew you to holography?
Were you involved with another medium first and uh sort of like changed over to holography or was holography your first love?
Well, um yeah, uh before as artist I kind of you know, play with all different medium like a painting or sculpture, those things.
Um but it's kinda I always feel like a two dimensional painting, they are too flat, too D and the uh sculpture to me is also kinda a little too real.
So until about ten years ago when I first time I saw hologram, I finally found these two elements, these two quality can be combining together.
Yeah.
Do you have your own laboratory?
Yes I do.
Um I have my studio in Manhattan.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, um what do you have inside what type of uh laser systems are you working with right now?
I have uh uh Hinam Niang uh laser and also um a a big table for that.
The table weighs two thousand pounds.
Yeah.
Um so and also some other size facilities.
Do you know what the uh power of a laser is?
It's a fifty million one.
Fifteen.
Fifty mil okay, uh one twenty five uh spectra.
Yeah, you know pretty well.
Okay.
Um as an artist working in holography, do you find sometimes you become frustrated because there's only so much you can do with the technology?
Um I have to say as a holographer you always have to you know, there are so many things unknown and happen during the the working, you know, procedure.
But but frustration never really coming from the limitation because I do feel maybe different other holographer, I do feel there's still so many things you can do uh for this medium.
And um you know apply to different ideas.
There's so many art, you know, things I haven't done yet.
Um and you know, if sometimes you get frustrated maybe because like uh you know, every good work it requires so many um you know, requirement like a stability or temperature whatever so many things.
Sometimes you don't get a very good result and you have to research in to see what happened.
And that kind of sometimes you have no way um to find out because there are not many people involved in this field and the support maybe not enough.
But other than that I'm pretty happy.
What's what's your process of coming up with a uh holographic work.
Uh do you sit down and think of a concept and perhaps maybe draw it out on paper first or is there a process that you find yourself going into from start to finish with a with a piece?
Um most of pieces they they will be coming from all different directions but yeah I do have to you know make a whole proposal together.
Since I my type of hologram it require like a a lot of multi exposures.
So sometimes I feel it's kinda like a even like a film production.
I have to have a you know after the concept and after I the idea ki starting to develop I maybe even do a storyboard or I even uh having a people actual people who are finally I'm I'm going to be in my hologram.
I will took the photo first as my sketch.
There's so many holograms out there where it's just the hologram and like you had mentioned earlier uh you work with installations and there are other th elements that are involved with your holographic work as well.
What are some of the things that you've combined with holography in your projects?
Um so far w the things I'm combining is all the different material objects like a some like a for example I have other pieces like a glass vase or the other the other piece I'm mounting the hologram on the fish tank.
And um and then you know I'm also will be working on more and more combining with some other materials or some other art form together.
I've I've been involved with holography for many years as well and I know that there's been comments out there saying that you know some people feel holography is a legitimate art form, other people do not and I would think that after all these years that that argument would have gone away but it still seems to be fairly prevalent out there.
Um how do you feel that this uh medium of holography could be looked upon as a legitimate art form?
A lot of times when you go out to see a hologram, you'll see a hologram of something of an object and for most people, you know why not just sit the object there instead of making a hologram of it.
Uh what's different about the type of work that you do that gets away from that thing of just reproducing something that already exists?
Well to look at that perspective like a even painting are is kinda r reproduced something the photography there reproduce something.
So I think the value is not how exactly these things reproduce the real object.
It's how and it's all according to how what kind of meaning the artist put into that work.
Otherwise I guess every artwork repres reproduce something else.
So um I don't know why I guess the hologram has a limitation is not a lot of people really know.
And also not a lot of people able to get into this medium.
So this medium always kind of has been and o you know so far not that popular.
So, you know, people kinda looking at that in a very interesting way because people keep thinking about the technical side rather than what the actual content those artists put into there because what grabbing you first is always, wow, that's so amazing.
Why why are you doing this?
How this happening.
So I guess that was something, you know, how people feel that.
But I guess if anyone who are seriously um or some art critic for or like any any audience or any um you know, they if they get really more serious about work, then they will get in there and then see what's a real expression the artist try to put in there.
It's like a every every other medium, like even I guess w even oil painting in one time was a new medium too.
And high tech at one time.
Yeah.
So like a pencil was high tech at one time.
So this is just like uh we are kind of m maybe in the time frame we are a little earlier.
So we have to be able to answer most of those questions about technical side.
What are the biggest barriers to having people get involved with holography?
What could we change about holography that would allow more people the opportunity to get involved with it, do you feel?
Well, first of all it's about this um requires so many equipment.
This v we make it very different than other uh our medium.
And those equipments, you know, is making like a m normal like our student they couldn't really reach and touch or to get in there and then to spend enough time.
It's like also like a even computer at the beginning.
You know, you see like uh all the students squeeze into one room and they all study from one big screen and now everyone got one in school and one at home.
So it's about like I guess I guess you have to make uh the equipment more um available for people and then that really depends on what you know if there's any like a major company they will be willing to put in more effort into this to make this more popular.
Do you think some of the companies that are uh dealing with these technologies, such as the laser manufacturers, your optical manufacturers and the people who manufacture the mounts, do you think that they should be putting more money back into the field to help people get involved with it?
It doesn't seem as if these companies contribute anything back into the field.
Yeah, it doesn't seem they're doing that, but I would like to see that because like uh, you know, if one day these things become more uh available for people, then um back to just now we're talking about people keep thinking about this technology things, it's like nobody will asking anyone how the photo developed.
Even nobody knows.
And how those city like a music city comp compact disc, how that works.
And nobody knows, but because it's so popular, so nobody asks.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Where do you see holography going in the future as far as maybe ten or twenty years down the road?
Um uh first I'd like to find out what some of your visions are on that.
And then I'll get back to you, uh, maybe asking you what do you think needs to take place in order for us to get there.
But where would you like to see holography in ten years?
What do you think we're going to be seeing with it?
You know, since this medium is so attractive, you know, by how many times when I had a show and how you see how people the audience responds to the world.
You know, you know, people like this.
And um so it's like a feel like a very you know interesting like it doesn't really go that far so far.
But but if the things are very attractive to people and you know I this is no reason it doesn't get big.
So I would see like it's supposed to be in the future um maybe those things can in state of I mean the closest one will be photography.
Um the photo ID whatever.
Um I guess ID will be the the most closest one like uh that can be really thing, three dimensional pe you know, people on the photo or ID, yeah.
And in order to get there, what do you think we need to overcome?
What what are some of the barriers that you see to getting there?
Again still back to the equipment's not that available and um and you need to have a kind of more and I I guess individually the those holographers if they don't have enough funding then you you cannot really push that far.
So again it's still have you know we have to see if there's any bigger manufacturing company they related to this and they'll be willing to put more energy on this side.
That's that's an issue that I hear a lot about as far as an artist will say that they don't have any funding so that they can't do any work.
I I try to you know I I still try to s you know using hologram to make a bigger hologram.
So somehow, you know, you know, if someone purchased a hologram, I put up money back to produce a bigger work.
And sometimes I have some commission work and I use that part of money to do, you know, to kind of going back to for the next project.
Um yeah, and yeah, that's the way kind of self-sufficient in that way.
How can someone find out more about your work?
Okay, um I have a website.
No, I'm going to have, but not yet.
Um I I because I I kind of show very frequently, um, I almost have about usually about ten exhibitions in one year.
And uh yeah, I should have my website, that's it.
Yeah.
Okay.
And we will include information.
I see you have your card here, so would it be alright for us to put your telephone number in case and your email address as well?
Of course, yeah.
And if anyone um you know heard this from the from the news and if you have any question, please welcome to call me or you can email to me.
Should I just re my yeah, my phone number, same as my fax number is Ariacall two one two six six two five nine six six.
And my email address is uh L I N Lin.
L I N at Sprintmail dot com.
Um L-I-N at S P R I N T M A I L dot com.
And my name is Shumin Lin.
It's spelled S H U M I N.
Shoe Min Lin, L-I-N.
Well, I thank you very much for being on the show.
It was very nice meeting you.
Yeah, me too.
Thank you.
We'll see you next week, everyone.
Take care.